SHOOTING, RIGHT?
IN
NOVEMBER AND ISLANDERS WON HERE
ONWON.
>> Sam: NICE RUSH DOWN THE ICE
BY FOX AND CHECKED ON THE PLAYP.
CIZIKAS WITH A LITTLE TAP-IN IN
FRONT AND ISLANDERS TAKE A 1-0
PULOCK MOVES IN.
PASS IN FRONT.
THEY SCORE.
A LITTLE TAP OPINION IN. MPASS S
THE CROSS BAR.
SHOT TOWARD THE NET.EN.
PAST NG ENOUGH AND VARLAMOV
VARLAMOV PUT IT IN THE CORNER.
ZIBANEJAD UP THE BOARDS.
LINDGREN IS THEREOYS, THAT'S IS
THE DIFFERENCE.
>> Sam: RANGERS ON THE POWER
D.
8:20 TO GO IN THE FIRST. PLAY
GOALS IN FIVE STRAIGHT GAMES AND
9 OFH THE NEW YORK
TROUBA.
UNDER A MINUTE TO GO
>> Sam: VARLAMOV STOPS T BY HUN.
A LITTLE SHAKE AND BAKE.
NICE PASS T T PERIOD.
HE DOES IT AGAIN.
ON THE MOVE.P LINDGREN.
ZIBANEJAD ABLE TO MOVOV HUNT.
MILLER AND
VARLAMOV.
>> Joe: STARTED WITH TROUBA.
A GOOD PASS UPES IN.
FINDS THE TRAILER.
THE SHOT.
SCORE! GIVE HIM SPACE AND ROOM
HE'LL FIND THE OPEN MANILL BUIL.
NICE PLAY BY GOODROW.
GOODROW MOVES IN AND  OR
HELMET.
AGAIN, REAL GOOD READ BY
GOODROW.
JUST ANTICIPATED WHEN T PELECH..
TR
PAGEAU BREAKSOD.
>> Joe: THE BEST SAVE BY
SHESTERKIN IN THIS GAME, JUSTLI
PAIR.
WON BY RANGERS WITH
POINTS BUT NO POINTS FOR THEUT
GOES TO HIM.
NEMETH IS ON HIS KNEES.
IT SLIDES WAHLSTROM MADE A GOOD
FROM BEHIND BUT HE HAD A WIDE
HERE IS PULOCK MOVIN